[Music]
rather grew up in molenbeek and feels at
home here his songs are about the people
who live here the 18 year old loves
molenbeek like most of the migrants here
his family was originally from Morocco
we all know each other not personally
necessarily but by sight we say hello to
each other no one would reject anyone
for me Mullin Beck is like a family most
Europeans see molenbeek differently that
is something raita finds hard to bear
Saleh and Brahim Abdeslam also grew up
in molenbeek they were involved in the
terrorist attacks in Paris in 2015 and
in Belgium in 2016 over 160 people were
killed and hundreds injured but Rader
says that doesn't mean other residents
sympathize with Islamist terror they
came from Mullin Beck unfortunately they
could have come from anywhere the
outside world thinks were all terrorists
but the Optus long brothers are not the
only radicals from Mullen Beck over 30
young jihadists went to Syria to fight
for the so-called Islamic state more
than from most other places in Europe
Caius boumaaza is a taxi driver he's
lived in molenbeek for almost 20 years
he says there is a very real danger of
radicalization he took us to a former
car workshop that's now used as a prayer
room DWS camera team was not welcome
cai-you says that young people here are
indoctrinated and there is rampant hate
speech against Western democracies he
says that Europe has to defend itself
this is Europe's weakness Europe is very
weak it can't impose its values people
are scared and others are making the
most of this to radicalize youths and to
commit crimes
politically case has hung the Belgian
flag on his balcony his answer to the
terrorist attacks which shattered his
world like many here he knew the
Abdeslam brothers personally he says
that he has tried to warn the
authorities and help the police since
the attacks but he says nobody will
listen to him he thinks that politicians
are worried of being accused of
Islamophobia if they clamp down on
prayer rooms where radical ideology is
preached they don't say that there's a
real terrorism problem in Belgium and in
Europe they're scared of not satisfying
the people of being unpopular boumaaza
is not alone in worrying about the
younger generation the social worker
Bashir in rabbit at this youth centre is
also doing his best to prevent
radicalization
he shows Raida and his friends a film
which is supposed to help young people
recognize propaganda on the Internet and
avoid falling into the trap of hate
preachers miss do you have a distance to
this or could this sort of stuff
influence you never the situation has
become calmer in Muhlenberg since the is
lost ground in Syria Olivier von der
Hagen says that has lost its attraction
for many youths here in Belgium he's in
charge of promoting equality in the
community he says one reason some young
Muslims are radicalized is because they
are not treated equally on paper Belgian
society is extremely tolerant there's
freedom of speech freedom of religion
but in actual fact there is exclusion
discrimination and racism vada and his
friends wrote this song which is about
how difficult it is to find a place in
society
I feel Moroccan oh really but you were
born here but I feel Moroccan
he's just so they feel half-and-half
they're very Belgian on the national
team plays they're really proud of the
Belgian Red Devils but there's still a
lot to be done in terms of identity
building nothing's clear yet they're
often not counted as Belgians this
doesn't help much the European
Commission is just a few kilometers away
and yet it's another world for the use
of molenbeek one they know very little
about and one that barely interest them
Rayder doesn't know what an ideal Europe
could mean but he wants a better future
for himself and for immigrants and
Muslims in general we should all be
equal and everybody's opinion should
matter and we should all take decisions
together
who knows maybe he'll write a song about
Europe one day and about how all people
live together on this continent
[Music]